انا لا ارى ضوءا في اخر
النفق في الحرب الاسرائيليه في
غز لا يبدو ان هناك وقت لاطلاق النار في
الوقت القريب او الوقت
المنظور الولايات المتحده ما تزال تعارض
وقفا لل النار في غزه القياده
الاسرائيليه تقول بان الحرب في غزه هي حرب
مفتوحه حرب شامله وانها تريد عده شهور
واكثر حتى اكثر من سنه والاخطر من ذلك ما
نشهده الان بان اسرائيل حقيقه تصعد في
حربها تصعد في حربها وتحاول حقي فتح
الجبهه الشرقيه ا الشماليه مع لبنان تريد
تغيير قواعد اللعبه ومع ذلك انا اعتقد ان
اهم المبادره الان هي المبادره المصريه
الافكار المصريه من اجل تبادل الاسرى
والمعتقلين بين اسرائيل
والفلسطينيين وايضا من اجل بدن انسانيه
ومن ثم وقف لاطلاق النار المبادره الوحيده
الموجوده على الطاوله نا هي المبادره
المصريه السؤال الرئيسي ان هناك مطبات
خطيره جدا في المبادره المصريه اولا يعني
هي هل تقبل اسرائيل بالمبادره الا المصريه
من اجل وقف اطلاق النار هل تقبل اسرائيل
بالكل مقابل الكل الكل اطلاق الرهائن
والاسرى الاسرائيليين مقابل المعتقلين
والاسرى الفلسطينيين ولكن في نهايه المطاف
يبدو ان قراءه النقديه بان رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنجمين نتنياهو مستقبله
السياسي يعتمد على مواصله الحرب لانه
عندما تهدا يعني المدافع في غزه يبدو ان
مستقبل رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنجمن
نتنياهو على المحك لان هناك بالفعل الان
نوع من شبه الاجماع في اسرائيل تحمل بنجمن
نتنياهو مسؤوليه الفشل الاستراتيجي في 7
اكتوبر بعد هجمات حماس الداميه على
اسرائيل ومن هنا انا اعتقد اننا لن نشهد
وقفا لاطلاق النار في الاسابيع المقبله
الا اذا قررت الولايات المتحده الضغط على
اسرائيل وهذا حتى الان لا يبدو ممكنا الا
اذا بالفعل
تم نوع من تصعيد الضغط الشعبي في اسرائيل
لان العديد من الاسرائيليين بدا يشعر بان
يعني الاهداف الاسرائيليه العاليه السقف
لم يتحقق منها الكثير هل استطاعت القياده
الاسرائيليه تحرير الرهائن
اللي هنا باسره ب حوز حباس هل استطاعت
اسرائيل قتل القيادات
الحماسيه يعني في غزه حركه حماس ما تزال
تقاوم ما تزال لديها القدره على الوجود
والصمود وهذا يعني بالفعل ان الراي العام
الاسرائيلي يمكن ان يبدا ان يسال اسئله
صعبه جدا تاخذ بعين الاعتبار اهميه هد
انسانيه او وقف لاطلاق النار اذا العاملين
الثلاث عوامل
الرئيسيه هل سوف تغير اداره جو بايدن موقف
موقفها اذاء وقف اطلاق النار حتى الان لا
ما هو طبيع الضغط الداخلي الاسرائيلي على
حكومه بنجمين نتنياهو وما هي قدره تفعيل
المبادره المصريه من اجد ايجال حل ولو
مرحله ووقف اطلاق النار في غزه هذه
الاسئله الثلاثه يمكن ان تعطينا نوع من
النظره السريعه على ما يحدث ويمكن ان يحدث
في غزه في الايام والاسابيع
القادمه
ه